[Música]
con toda la economía esto de la mano de
quien más sí no daniela blandón dan y
vamos a hablar de las claves económicas
que dejó este debate presidencial en
francia lo que estábamos conversando
también con luis miguel agregó raúl y es
que para nadie es un secreto que el
costo de vida ha sido catalogado como el
tema más importante para los franceses
en esta elección durante el debate los
candidatos reiteraron sus propuestas uno
de los pilares de manuel macro es una
transición más rápida hacia las energías
renovables algo que marie le pen no
comparte macrón también le apunta a
mantener el bloqueo a los precios de la
electricidad y otorgar incentivos
fiscales para que las empresas
bonifiquen a sus trabajadores ahora si
analizamos a marín lepén pues ella
quiere eliminar el iva por lo menos a
100 bienes de consumo y recortar el
gasto público pero es un contrincante se
esmeró en recordarle que todavía no ha
explicado cómo va a financiar su
programa uno de los puntos más
controversiales es el de la edad de
jubilación que hoy es de 62 años
cuanto antes trabaje es más duro
trabajar así antes tendrás que irte y
por eso propongo un sistema que sea
progresivo todos aquellos que hayan
tenido un primer trabajo significativo
antes de los 20 años entre los 17 y los
20 podrán jubilarse a los 60 años y
paulatinamente según la edad de ingreso
al sistema obviamente es muy diferente
del proyecto del señor macro que quiere
hacer que todos trabajen hasta los 65
años
ya que sólo hay una manera de
financiarse es trabajar más poco a poco
con un pilar que es el empleo podemos
hacerlo porque el trabajo para mí es un
hilo conductor y un segundo pilar es
cambiar la edad legal que hoy es 62 por
cuatro medias al año es decir que en el
2028 subiría a 64 años de edad y en 2031
a 65 años y seguimos en europa ni porque
alemania prometió desligarse del
petróleo ruso bueno no nos olvidemos de
que uno de los principales obstáculos
que ha tenido europa para castigar más
duramente al kremlin han sido su
altísima dependencia del petróleo y del
gas provenientes de ese país y a lengua
es uno de los más necesitados de estos
energéticos sin embargo el gobierno
confía en que está listo para reversar
esta situación rafael pérez nos cuenta
cómo planean hacerlo
no más petróleo importado de rusia para
fin de año ese fue el plan quería
conocer la ministra de relaciones
exteriores de alemania como parte de las
sanciones contra el kremlin por la
invasión a ucrania alemania está
eliminando completamente las
importaciones de energía de rusia
reduciremos el petróleo a la mitad para
el verano y estaremos en cero para fin
de año son más
de arbes jacques en el saint las
declaraciones fueron formuladas en riga
capital de letonia en el contexto de una
reunión con sus homólogos de lituania
estonia y el canciller anfitrión en el
encuentro se dejó clara la posición de
los 27 miembros de la unión europea en
cuanto a cortar las dependencias
energéticas de moscú pero al final del
día déjenme recordarles que no sólo
alemania los estados bálticos deciden
sobre las sanciones son los 27 estados
miembros y es una decisión unánime es
nuestra decisión común al comienzo de la
invasión a ucrania rusia aportaba el 55
por ciento del gas que consumía alemania
lo que la convierte en una de las
naciones más cautelosas a la hora de
aplicar sanciones a los combustibles
rusos danny cuál es la actualización de
la batalla del estado de la florida
contra disney bueno le puedo anticipar
primero que esta no será una historia de
cuentos de hadas al final del abismo las
de mí con disney porque mire el
gobernador ron de santis consiguió que
el senado de florida de mayoría
republicana le aprobara la eliminación a
partir de junio de 2023 de seis
distritos especiales que fueron creados
en 1967 y en ellos se incluye reedy
creek improvement que es el distrito
donde opera disney esta última es un
área de unos 100 kilómetros cuadrados en
la que la multinacional tiene su propio
gobierno la reprimenda del gobernador
contra la multinacional se dio después
de que ésta le retirara toda la
financiación política al estado y se
pronunciara en contra de la recién
aprobada norma que limita la discusión
de temas lgbt en las escuelas ahora este
jueves el proyecto pasa escrutinio de la
cámara estatal también republicana antes
de pasar por el escritorio de bronce
santis para su firma final es un país
prácticamente eso ya es un país aparte
existen buenos indicadores económicos
los principales índices de referencia de
las bolsas subieron en japón-corea del
sur en australia
impulsados por el repunte del jueves en
europa y de las principales operaciones
antes de mercado de wall street que son
positivas en efecto en europa operan al
alza las bolsas en francia
particularmente el mercado recibió con
mucho positivismo el debate presidencial
y avanza casi un 2% media jornada dar y
gracias como siempre por toda la
información económica mañana seguimos
conversando de más economía en directo
américa pasamos a saludar a umar esa con
los deportes